- Captain's Log, final entry
Spock and I are the sole survivors
Enterprise, are you there?
- Good morning, Wendy
- Good morning, Scotty
- Can we go over your everyday schedule?
- Wake up, go to work
Welcome to Cinnabon, would you like a Cinnabon?
- How's your script coming?
- I just wrote a story where Spock travels to Deep Space 9
- That sounds awesome
- 3PM: Take Pete for a walk
- 6PM: Watch Star Trek before I go to bed
- Send in your script highlighting the best of the Star Trek universe
- Next week, your sister's coming
- There's a Star Trek script writing contest
We can go to the post office,
and then I can go home with you
Can you please tell Audrey that I'm ready to go home now?
- Please stand by
Breathe
- Your completed script must be received by February 16th
- Where are you going?
- Los Angeles
Bus driver: my friend needs to pee
Don't do it, Pete!
This is what happens when you pee on the bus
- Me and my boyfriend, we're actually going down to L.A.
Maybe you should just come with us
- She's 5 foot 4, blonde
- That's her
- I know he's the hero of Star Wars,
but who exactly is this Kirk person?
- She's out there, alone
- She's a very resourceful girl
- GIVE ME MY NOTEBOOK BACK!
Where am I?
- You're at the hospital, you hit your head
- She jumped out the window!
- How did she get away from you people?
- (foreign language)
- What language is that?
- It's Klingon
- Your sister is one of the most complex
and creative people I know
- People have their own lives,
and after awhile, those lives don't include you
- Captain, there is only one logical direction in which to go
Forward
- Light: it can travel for millions of years
before finally reaching its destination
Do you know how hard it is to write something?
Because the story you want to tell means so much to you?
It goes lonely and alone,
hoping that it will reach someone
- That's amazing
So, what happens next?
- The unknown is there for us to conquer,
not to fear
- What was Leonard McCoy's daughter's name?
- Joanna
- Oh, snap!
- Pay up!